that's bright
alright let's do this thing hey everyone
how's it going long time no see it's
been a hot minute since I posted my last
video which probably was like a month or
a month and a half ago
I hope YouTube surfaces this video for
y'all cuz I am NOT friends with the
algorithm right now and I think it's
hurting me but you know whatever it's
not even about the numbers so either way
it is good to be back and I am excited
to tell you kind of what's been going on
and I'm guessing that you clicked on
this video because you wanted to know
about all of this where do I even like
start for this okay so I left my job at
patreon on October 12 so yes that was
over two months ago now and I kind of
wanted to talk about why and what's been
going through my mind the last two to
three months I don't know I guess I
don't I don't owe this to anyone but I I
just really wanted to talk about it
because why not this is my creative
outlet I want to be able to talk about
stuff okay so this is one of those
videos it's just like oh I left my
software engineering job and I
completely understand how much of a
place of privilege that I come from to
be able to leave a job like that and
also have the option to do all the
things that I've been doing basically so
I completely understand and I know that
I am so fortunate to be in this position
so let me start off saying that just
wanted to put that out there
so I go to therapy I have been going to
therapy for I think about two years now
and I first started going because I had
anxiety and panic attacks and stuff and
I was so sick of feeling so anxious all
the time so that's what started it since
then I have gotten over a lot of my
anxiety and panic attacks stuff thank
God and I started going just to kind of
talk to someone about my feelings and my
thoughts which has been the most useful
thing so my current therapist I started
going to her because I was like hey I
think that the thing that is missing
from my life right now that is not
allowing me to reach my goals is
discipline it's funny because through a
lot of sessions and stuff I realized I
was like so wrong and thinking about
that I mean I think I do like lack
discipline in some things obviously but
that was not the true thing that I
needed to think about and work on so one
of the exercises that my therapist gave
me is to draw out literally visualize
what kind of life do I want to live in
the future so talking about it with my
therapist and kind of thinking about
what I drew that day it made me really
reflect on what do I want in life
and how am I going to get there I really
like being able to spend an hour or not
thinking about the time and drinking a
cup of tea and really enjoying how good
like milk teas or just like sitting down
and listening to music or just
appreciating my dogs company like these
are all things that I really like to do
I'm an over-thinker
I'm also an over feeler and so I really
enjoy the time that I get to kind of
just put life on pause and basically
process everything which I know I've
talked about in a lot of videos but
really that's really important to me
among other things I really like being
able to be productive and feel like I'm
useful and kick ass at something like
those those are also feelings that I
really like chasing too and in order to
do all of those things and live the life
that I want I really need to be good at
managing my intake of the world and also
my out take my output of the world as
well because if I input too much then I
literally have so much to process and if
I output too much I'm literally just too
exhausted to even input anything into my
brain anyway this is really abstract and
I'm sure if this it's like none of this
makes sense but it did really make me
reflect on you know what do I want what
kind of life do I want to live and when
I compares what I wanted in life to the
life that I was actually living it was a
lot of input and a lot of output and not
enough time to process anything I was
trying to make every single minute of my
life super productive and worthy and I
wasn't wasting any time and that's like
the complete opposite of what kind of I
wanted to do which makes sense right
like most people are like hey let's
figure out how to be the most productive
person you can be let's make sure that
you are quantifying your stuff against
your goals like that's totally fine like
that works for some people and great
like you found the system that works for
you I think I had tried that and I did
oh I did a lot of that like mental
calculation and it was honestly just
really exhausting for me and so I
realized like tangibly the things that I
needed in life was a lot more
flexibility in terms of flexibility in
the time that I had or flexibility to
feel things in the moment or flexibility
to I don't know kind of make decisions
on my own that best suited my needs I
really just really just needed to slow
down like a lot so how this all ties
back into like why I left patreon is cuz
I feel like I hit a breaking point where
I realized that working there wasn't
going to give me the time and
flexibility and the kind of life that I
really wanted it took me a long time to
figure that out because patreon was my
dream job like I loved working there
like that still doesn't change even
after I have moved on but the things
that I really liked about the job and
the actual execution of like what it is
to work at that job were two different
things
and I was constantly managing my
relationship with work at this point
I spent like three hours a day commuting
to and from my work which I did the math
I have spent three months in total
commuting to and from patreon during my
time there which like that's so much
time I mean I was really sad to leave
that job though cuz it was my dream job
like I said I really still personally
aligned with the mission that they're
going after and I am and was still so
passionate about being a part of that
and wanting to do good in the world by
creators and their fans I mean I was
able to realize kind of like this
lifelong goal that I had of starting a
YouTube channel while at patreon because
I was surrounded by so many great
creative people and really motivated and
awesome passionate people who were
really interested in the arts and I
learned so much as a software engineer
and as a person I got to me and work
with so many incredible individuals
there that I totally would have been
like a completely different person and
had I not worked there so I am so truly
grateful for the time that I had there
which was two and a half years and yeah
it was so hard leaving honestly like I
it felt like a breakup I'm still a
little bit sad to be honest and as tough
as it was I am so glad to work there and
I think it was the right decision for me
to leave so after I left I took six
weeks off which I am so lucky and glad
that I did because I took six weeks just
to kind of decompress between jobs and
it was nice I felt like I was on like
summer vacation again and I really got a
lot of time to myself
which was kind of making up for lost
time honestly you know I was like
commuting so freaking much I didn't
really do like a whole lot during my six
weeks I honestly just hung out and like
decompressed did like chores and stuff
that I had been wanting to do for a
while like this whole dining room behind
me I did turn my six weeks off because I
just wanted to make my home feel more
comfy and cozy
me and I slept a lot and I can't and it
was such a good time and during this
time I didn't make any videos because
one of the things that I think was kind
of a I don't know like a source of
pressure or stress for me during this
whole thing was I felt like I needed to
make videos because I had to like if I
didn't like something bad would happen
and it became this thing that I had to
do instead of something that I wanted to
do and so the creativity wasn't flowing
and I was not really having fun so I
decided to just put a pause on it for
now that's why there haven't really been
any videos so I'm sorry but it was so
helpful because now I feel like my
creative juices are flowing again and I
feel motivated and excited and I feel
like I want to make videos again so it
was time well spent
I feel mentally emotionally physically
like my body and everything was just
relaxing and it was so needed so after
my six weeks I did start a new job and I
am really enjoying it my commute is so
much shorter it's like 20 minutes one
way so nowhere near how long I was
commuting to go to patreon and I feel so
much more balanced in all of the ways
that said I don't necessarily feel like
I have all the answers yeah and I'm not
like completely like I'm not a
completely self actualized human being
honestly it's all a process but I how I
do feel like I've caught up to my
feelings and my thoughts a little bit
more and I feel like I can work through
them better and I feel like I'm a better
person I feel like I'm truer to myself I
don't know it might be very like
American for me to be like live your
truth but I think that's an important
thing to do like we only get so much
time on this earth so you know live your
truth as best as you can
so yeah that's where I've been for like
the last two months and sorry that I
haven't been making videos I
kind of just been taking time to myself
and I don't know what making videos is
going to look like in the future but I
do have ideas brewing and I'm just
hoping it can convert those ideas into
actual videos execute on them but if
there are types of videos that you
really want to see that maybe I've done
one of before maybe I've done none of
leave a comment down below to let me
know what types of videos you want to
see more of okay well that's it I guess
how do I do this again like this video
and like subscribe or something okay I
think that's it for today so I'll see
you next time bye
I left my job at patreon out then why do
you bite me
[Music]